cycling is a very physically demanding  sport you are the engine on the bike and  the harder you work the faster you go  it's that simple so it's very important  that you you are correctly before you go  back training and it's very important  that when you come back you replace the  energy lost and you start that whole  repair process recovery is essential  post training because you want to get  back on your feet as quickly as possible  doesn't matter whether you're competing  a high level or just training to stay  fit the principle is the same  Rigo rapid recovery plus is scientist  sports one stop for recovery it's  essentially whey protein carbohydrates  vitamins minerals branched chain amino  acids l-glutamine all in one product and  you take that force training or  competition and it's going to speed up  the process of recovery and make you  feel better for the next session  [Music]